اما في ملف الاحتجاجات ومع زياده قمع
القوات الامنيه والانتشار المكثف لها في
الشوارع الايرانيه وقطع الطرقات اضافه الى
الوضع الاقتصادي السيء تعذر على الاف
المحتاجين الايرانيين الوصول لنقاط التجمع
ما دفعها هؤلاء الى تغيير الاستراتيجيه
للتظاهر وتمثلت بتشكيل مجموعات صغيره في
كل حي وحاره على ان تكون خاطفه بمعنى ان
المتظاهرين يخرجون في تظاهرات محدوده
وسريعه لاسيما فتره الليل هتافات وتصوير
ثم العوده للمنازل وقد رصد اسلوب
الاحتجاجات الخاطف هذا في مناطق كرديه
متعدده بينها سلندرش وكذلك العاصمه طاهره
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
مواقف عده في لوازم معي الشيا للايرانيين
وحقوقهم الاساسيه دفعتهم للشارع مرارا على
مدى سنوات طويله وما بدا في سبتمبر الماضي
كاحتجاجات على مقتل الشاب ماسه امينه
والدفاع عن حقوق النساء تشحدها مظالم
اقتصاديه كثيره وفق صحيفه واشنطن فالعمله
المحليه اي الريال سجل ادنى مستوياتها في
ديسمبر مكمله انهيار كامل امام الدولار
شهر ديسمبر شهد كذلك تجاوز معدل التضخم
48% وهو اعلى مستوى له منذ اكثر من 25
عاما التاثير الاولي لهذا التضخم ينعكس
بطبيعه الحال على معيشه الناس والمكافحه
لتغطيه نفقاتهم وفقا الصحيفه الامريكيه
فالسياء الشعبي زاده حده ارتفاع التكاليف
حتى باتت المواد الغذائيه الاساسيه مثل
اللحوم والبيض هذا وكان
خرجوا بمظاهرات واسعه اواخر عام 2019
احتجاجا طبعا على ارتفاع اسعار الوقود
لكنها انتهت بسقوط اكثر من 1500 قطيفه
[موسيقى]